primera jornada corta pero intensa la
que vivió joe biden en su llegada a
israel el presidente estadounidense
arribó en el air force one sobre las
tres y media de la tarde y en el mismo
aeropuerto de tel aviv fue recibido por
el presidente israelí isaac here shock y
el premier israelí en funciones y aísla
pitt estados unidos e israel' forman en
sus palabras una amistad y ésta quedó
retratada en los discursos de bienvenida
en gestos de camaradería y en una foto
de familia que también incluyó al ex
primer ministro y actual líder opositor
benjamín netanyahu las alocuciones
aunque también breves sirvieron para
marcar algunos de los temas de esta
primera gira de vaivén por medio oriente
como presidente mientras la habló
de una coalición global contra irán
vaivén que visita israel por décima vez
en su carrera política reiteró el
compromiso de eeuu con la seguridad de
israel y defendió en una solución de dos
estados para el conflicto
palestino-israelí admitiendo luego que
no la ve posible a corto plazo esta
defensa israelí se plasmó desde el mismo
aeropuerto con una exhibición
armamentística que tuvo como principal
atracción el prototipo de un láser
antimisiles
iron bean que como la cúpula de hierro
podría beneficiarse de financiación
estadounidense luego badén se trasladó a
jerusalén oeste y allí rindió tributo a
las víctimas del holocausto en el museo
yad vashem donde además diálogo con dos
sobrevivientes judías e instó a combatir
el veneno del antisemitismo fuera de lo
simbólico incluso antes de su aterrizaje
en by denny lápiz firmaron un pacto de
cooperación para el desarrollo de
tecnologías centrado en la inteligencia
artificial un acuerdo antesala de los
anuncios oficiales que se esperan este
jueves después de que bailen y lápiz
tengan su primer cara a cara solas como
mandatarios un foro virtual con los
líderes de emiratos árabes unidos e
india y encuentros con here shock y
netanyahu completan la agenda política
de bailén antes de desplazarse el
viernes a territorios palestinos y
arabia saudita